Who's out here who want to get forked?
Okay, right luck yo fuck you. Huh fuck him
Well what the hell we're execute fuck you. Oh, yeah, I didn't help no you buddy. Huh? Who's Gonna clock
This window fuck you
Lock me up top. Oh there up. Top one climbing in our dorm you got a mark woman
Uh welcome oh my God the hell is happening. I don't know. He's just teleporting oh
You did well
I did not work didn't know there's money others Bob's dead body, okay?
well, I
Meant to die in this endeavor. Wait. I really do want to charge into death
Okay, you want to take this jeep here and just drive it in and no that's not good sheep. They're mine. They're mine
That did not good jeep you get it. I'll be right behind
Let's go face death just we'll go up to rock and die there right marker. Yeah, let's do that
Okay, we'll join you soon
Sorry really wish I wasn't running behind you but I guess I'll just try to appreciate the view for what it is. Thanks
I'm an pants. Let's go got a democrat you're talking the least intimidating social trading disease
Thank you. Fully decked out - pants. Thank you. Oh get in the car. Let's go get
You you drive. I don't know how to drive. Let's go get fucked
Drive it. - I don't know death. Whatever the most death got it yes, nyah. Fuck it all right
Yeah, hey, buddy, want a good fuck. I'm sure going full speeding this this particular vehicle will never in wait wait
No, I trust my driver. I trust him be good. Whatever is don't worry
Yeah, I just start shooting wildly to announce our location figure out how to honk
is fun
Hahaha, sit down
buddy
Yeah, keep walking into that way come on. Yeah Throttle is. That's a fence
Yeah
They are they're trying pretty aggressively to actually kill
Define dukes the hazard, right?
Go ahead boy
Yes, Knight is just like
Fuck you fucking here
everybody
Everyone is so terrified of the honking this is what oh don't look out there
We're gonna find it. We I throw up. We gotta target up. Go get him not visiting it. Yeah, y'all know interest
Rate I don't even know where their
little way, I don't care right, they're
Taking oval time there we go
No is the crap out of them
You make a bobble head oh
Yeah, I got a car
Guys want to get in the car and miss fuck off. Hey, let us in the right direction before I died
Thanks, wade you're welcome. You guys want a shotgun or maybe I had a vest on me. I don't remember what I had
Hey, how's it going? Hey? What's up guys? What's up? I'm hearing Darius get in the car
He's from here where we're going where to I don't care just honk so the travel guide drive over good George's alright
Yeah, fuck. Nope. We do hxs. What what oh Red bread you got it
So you're doing here right site resides. Oh, that ain't good
Hey, I killed so
Allows it sure you think it was my honking that announced us. We could go water Village George poll
Shooting range shooting range kind of sucks in my experience. I don't know yeah sometimes you get bad news
Is there a week ago ruins and then go George boole? I'm into that okay?
Race it go, whoo
That's about it
Thank you, wait is the ruins the one in the bayou or the one that looks like ruins the flooded city ah shit
That's not good. That's cool. It's cool. Get it cool school
Yeah, it's fine
You think I don't know what I'm going for he says what he's happy when things are going well dogs are disliked. Oh
Alright, okay. I got a I got a scar and a helmet and a bike a pang cool bike a pike
I'm not try to rendezvous with you Bob
What's your shooting that wade was a bad guy on this roof bad guy?
Or any of us really okay first?
Um so one of them's over here
Don't know where the other one is I'm gonna move towards wade then back behind me. I didn't hit oh my God
I got a hitler I got a hero. Oh, God
Alright, just trying to get I'm trying to get to spot work and help you out mark. Oh, man. I'm almost dead
Call where a shot came from you came from Southeast I think
Pretty sure is behind me not on Earth. That's where Jack is oh mom. Oh, God. There's a guy here. Oh like why?
Where is there things out there ears? Yeah? Walk? He was just sitting in the corner?
Yeah, I see him by this with him I see him I
Got him
Whoops that was super laggy, but yeah, sorry you need health in a bad way
I know I'll be joining us soon in the afterlife here
Anybody got a saudi pop to top me off
Yeah, I got I got some heels for you market
You want some other without that where you have my time in the building with you guys?
I'm gonna mourn over a friend a friend here
I'll drop you some of this and so that you go just steal right up there, buddy
God my energy monster, and yeah, you know that. That's the act energy drink. You fucking remember him you do well
Oh like defeat MmM, Corrado's helmet level three a little dude. I fucking love Guarana
That's the best player all right. I'm just going to use all these bandages if you goes good
Go for it. We don't need them. We don't get shot like a bitch wow okay?
Wow
Been an American servers that are already laggy for American
Mm-Hmm all I heard a bunch of excuses, and we don't tell her that Jenner. This is this is buttery smooth
You know it is to level two homeless in this building. I already got one crow
Dude, what about frozen Mark Iii got a level one. I like to play a hard mode. So where should we go?
They're fillers. I don't know somewhere where after I would feel really bad
Did you know excluded from I just find a rifle known well? You should go to George Paul. I it's in the circle
That's a valid point. That's where all shits Gonna. Go down, so
All right lee to Georgia pole Tigers bird you headed there. Yeah, I'm headed I'm heading out Towards George
Pool you think you'd tell me you can't. Loot me in only 2 min what I'm just trying to die man
That's what I'm out for it's just reconnected hi
Okay, what's going on deck over that wall join nation to it?
Lovely up here is it fun?
Now I'm bored as fuck it to look at all. You douche bags. Okay, wait. That's waiting rifle right here
Oh, we're going to be rifled. It's a it's an M4 or 16 weird though. There's no ammo with it. I don't know what happened
Also, I implore
Shut up man, damn God's watching
Thank God
Whether your pen, no, I want you to watch
Bro, are you doing this one-handed right now? Hell? Yeah, I'm not even mad. I'm just impressed
I do my life one-handed bro. Whoa that that's a thing. Oh, you're a buggy buggy buggy
Kill kill fucking over near me. That's a bike. I like kill kill
Going up the hill. It's going Towards, Georgia Pole
Whoo those are hit wait let him up we got a couple of hoods. I got like two hit sir
Did you guys shoot until ye yeah? Okay? Y'all I got him? His bike is fucked. Yeah
Where'd he go? Yes?
Did he leave he went way up there? Yeah? He's gone. Gone. Did you get the gun wade? No where was it?
It's all the fucking marker. God okay. I'm gonna take a sec here right here. Why do I do anything for you?
I don't there's a came right here
Wait what I said about listening yeah? Oh, oh, I won't take that from them now from the south wade from the tower here
From the Sap from the south they hurt my level three helmet as a head shot. Yeah, where is that?
Where is that persons? I don't know behind us in the Runes or something
Yeah, I think they are right amer over there on the right hand side from you Bob like you can I think like oh?
I see a guy on foot 210 for me I
Can't I don't have a shot on but he's on foot heat. They're moving right now. Okay, move up
I'm Gonna move up
I only saw one, but it's either a teammate of the guy, whose bike we fucked up
Or it's another squad dropping my decked-out shotgun here if anyone want the decked out shot Gunderson five five six
Leave Rashad. Go. Where'd you go friends, but they're to the
South south south of us moving moving to South west yeah
Like trying to get up the hill, but I don't know where they went
I don't know where that shot came from but I feel like this is not a good place for me to be right now
There's not a floor hey. How's it going? Oh?
haha
Go fucking stand over there. Oh
That's scary. We were started reading bid on me
It's brain it was on but how to do it rain in me yeah, I can't see him
He must have gone into the brick yeah, I'm just looking to eat here. He's just laying down way when our out. There is where?
People to marker on him
and a Rock I
Can't shoot this wall from there. Yeah. I saw him on the right side
But he's probably maneuvering around to get a better shot
Shooting rocks like no close to it's a big rock from that big rock there a bit off the hill right now
Man, I can't hit shit
I can't see it right now mark season. Look like my shoes. He wearing will I get me one now moving again. Oh
Good hit, and we got need I have a frag I wanna. He's got a park over there
Light it up
Hop-Hop you got it and his friend was like. I'm gonna fuck you. Oh your knob down up down
Yeah, I knocked out one of them. You want to help you. I'm getting shot from the top of the hill I see
Toppled by that bush uh-huh I think it's really bold that they put a report button in every time you die
Yeah, that's good applies report everyone. Yeah. I think there is more than one squad that we're currently engaged with Mm-hmm. Yeah
That's the thing about squads is like
It's so hard when we try to scoop on my body if you want to go out there
I had two two two exes way to tie a nice phone right there. Yeah, oh
You have marketing you could do it. Oh really you gotta really look at me
He's just prone in the grass or unless he moved I popped below the hill to see I
Don't know where he just saw him like you just saw him eat right there. Yeah
Nice. Hey
What about the other one their squad is gone then yeah, just died wait
Here's a lot of the hill he thought he said right someone just smoked
Look, I think that we got I think that was him the guy that wade killed those smokes
Take a like a few seconds to pop okay. Oh, that wasn't a smoke that was this car
Dying no that was definitely a smaller that was smoke, okay? I thought I heard a smoke grenade be thrown it was all
Yeah, oh
My God mark. I was spectating market when you went to loot you like breach town and pick something up and his body disappeared
Did you pick up any heels by chance? I got a painkiller?
I'm gonna you need I had a first aid kit on my body
There's a bunch of four five six here to market community. I didn't steal it you can use budget make the first date
I just took the bandages. Oh you guys aren't invited either that's exciting basically or
I'm trying to watch for anyone running up
I feel like they would have shot at you by now kiss weights just been standing in the open for a while
Go friends when they live a hill charge eat some chicken dinner and stuff like 39 people left only
37 for us to kill marks we got a
Few teams you only need them all to kill another vehicle right here. Oh
So there were two squads or something another one of them don't just leave they all they killed those guys let's go
I debate you guys that are kind of a wise thing to do if we had seen two other squads
we should have been like ah
let's let them kill each other you bet there's someone in that building ah
Check it out about this someone in the building let's move in only one way to find out
Let me go get away when the doors open. I think these doors are always open. Oh, oh
It's a garage I see yeah, that's uh weight weights in there right now mark. I think I think instigators creator
I can throw a grenade mean
He's not in there, so if you really want to throw a grenade like I guess you can just let him pretend
I am sitting good out of his system, but not actually kill
You even me now trade
Thing over the thing lady jean good bones. No, I'm cooking dinner. Please another first aid kit. You want it
I've got three and a med kit you go ahead. Okay my favorite
It's when you go into the building like this, and then you open one of these doors
And there's just a dude there with the shot, but like surprise motherfucker like my least favorite possible circles
I hate when this mountain is in there mmm, so it's like king of the mountain. What do you got against Mountain weights?
Well, it sucks like the first one up there because this is a hundred teams that push and suck
So there's someone else up there because they always target you
And then the other team comes up kills them and you maybe just be good and kill them all okay
Yeah, that's what I think you're right. You're when you're right. You're right, and you just need to get good way. I mean times
I'm sorry. Yeah, you are hello
Sorry excuse love the next circle. Just hunting the sink I
Am oh
I
Get it explain to us why you're nicely the circle. I was thinking it was going yet now ready to go die wait
Yeah, what do you want to die on top of the mountain or under the mountain?
They get fun guys come on. Yeah making good for the viewers me die at Boba
That's the challenge, okay alright. Wait. What are you going for here? Oh well?
We go to this building complex interest track fighting to hold a building okay?
One death is as good as another in my opinion
Here's where the awm on the mountain just single-shot headshot this both real quick on our way. Well. I got a level two helmet
It's gonna be good right. Yeah, it can it's a
New girl with it's as good at - it's the one I got off of that dead guy, you know, it's good
If that happened to uh there's a place
I would see only in last night there was someone just laying in the middle of a field and no one saw him until they
Ran into I couldn't get past and the configure would happen so the guy turned around and shot them so are you suggesting?
We be the people in the middle of the field or we be the the inept people stumbling across well because people
We're more like Mountain
Take the mountain I don't want to take that none dominate I see fire
On the mountain your gain yourself become the mountain. I was a lot of the thrones reference
We're we're not we're not going to throne or dragon or move it up
We're just going to grab it up now game with friends is about boot Dragon Tagliabue for track
You still are you one of those people who hasn't watched game of thrones?
So I have not seen anything
I might into the commercial for it even a seen it either you think there's someone a
motorcycle right above us over there right above us where where zaba North
Part about me where those rocks are top of those rock star by the mouth see the guy walking up the mountain right there
Right wait up to the right. I saw the tree yeah I see him way to the right yeah, that's not the motorcycle
I won't upon over that Adam squad they parked the motorcycle behind that ridge and our climbing up the mountain should we shoot out there?
Behind that Ridge. We're gonna get some hyper life isn't that crate no boy. I I see him at the mount don't engage them
They're going to give you the d
What if we give them the d? I mean you could try but now? I'll follow we give each other the d
Not like you need but like the Team's
By the way, it's what you meant
well, I guess it's about encircle, so
wait, Love Smart
Ah we're going to we're going to be each other you're going to go for the mountain
While we have to look at the circles, I guess I mean maybe we should like um the bullets
Oh, hey there peeking over the top of the ridge there at 60 from you mark
the very top of the Mountain
Is a cube where ah wait right there wait there we go?
There was another one up to the right from where that dude was also in that little
Crack Doolin Little heinous
sweet Little Mountain crack
Oh wade you're so far
Ahead of me never gonna be very good way to secret stair seeing the shit out of this all right?
I don't know about no secret stairs, so I'm just gonna take I don't know why there's I'm just trying to run
Oh, that's a lot. Oh that's so close to you. Would you know that's fun?
Oh, I think I'm in trouble so much shooting from behind me run mark judges go on it
I gone for it. I'm a man
Live oh boy
I know if you guys win
I'm Gonna be sad oh my God where?
What is like Ted feet away from all that murder you got just a few spot away wait. Don't wait. I'm couple otto coming in
maybe if I can get up the goddamn mountain
Anyway now
slowly
surely, maybe not surely but slowly definitely with the foot with the trixie frag ah
you guys have advantage you should rush um we've got a few hits into his office ah
Get auto Auto Zone, baby circle the guy down there throw a grenade
there grenade fuckin like bounce out that dude says
He pops up and you turn and look if you're like take this
No, no, the circle got to move way get a circle
Just forget me
Forget about me
Very on my memory. I'm dead. Oh, I was like right there. I ended the circles if you wait, all right?
Yeah that guy will I think that guy went down?
God of course I chose that one moment to pull my frag out, I'd uh uh
stupid
Kevin's a six left alive jesus yeah, I think there's still more to your north wind on the other side of the ridge
Yeah, that way. I think there there are definitely guys over there. I mean, you just want to stay in cover at this point
You have a circle sing dictate. I move it in a second well. This is true. You can do it
Oh, my heart is grace. You're good
Krusty Krab Pizza throw a grenade. It's not always worrying me
okay, now just pull them out pull out a grenade and then switch to your weapon again apparently to show up when you pull a
critter hit yeah
Too quiet for there being five other people yeah, they're all just laying down and not being crazy people
so if you gonna mull do fine, right ah
Pdp Kebab yes engage each other
Murder each other this is your can wade I?
Like how you gave up the high ground to the year on the low ground I wanted to cover Clever strategy no one would ever
Foresee that or last wait. I hear skippy steps, but I'm not going to distract it with my stupid ideas
I'm dead. What do I know how true that is you in the circle wait? Oh?
Kind of bothersome that kind of there the guys have to come off the mountain to get to it. Oh
Hey, there's a guy
Charge them oh
Wait, oh God toward him there
It's coming find you he's rushing
Yeah, go for the guy behind you cuz then you get the low ground and a little more cover. Oh
oh, God, oh
my men shit
I did yeah, and or that fire if I were fired if I had had if I didn't do the stupid Grenade move
Maybe maybe we would add that well you can blame me you can all blame me. Oh, I'm lending it
She's not a bad kid. I would have been
Like died immediately so I think I was a liability
No, I mean yeah
but nah come on
*outro song*